more than a million job vacancies
235,000 Seavey's you as the European
jobs network hosts around 6,000
employers but only three percent of the
available European labor force our
mobile setup in 1993 the European jobs
network was designed to facilitate the
free movement of workers within the
European Economic Area at the heart of
reform the inclusion of a maximum number
of existing job services via valen canal
yet in this a father the massive and
Bing dong Dupree Vartan Abbott's
familiar via volunteer and pinned on the
array Conine outlets familiar the Avanti
and pinned on their sochi I partner
Vince ang bata marking futures before
the end pending from NGOs Vince's tune
but signing up to it isn't compulsory
for member states or for job seekers
it's not mandatory for anyone and nobody
can be compelled to take a job that
advertised on us and nobody can have
their benefits cuts if they don't to
service to make it easier for people who
want and there are millions and millions
and millions of people across the EU who
do indeed desperately want to find work
by the end of 2015 the number of people
active works in the sky high 22 million
that's a rate of unemployment of nine
percent
you